[Music]
use the stones again we'd be going in
short-handed you know look you still got
the stones so that's gonna use them to
bring everyone back just like that yeah
just like that
even if there's a small chance that we
can undo this I mean we owe it to
everyone who's not in this room to try
if we do this how do we know it's gonna
end any differently than it did before
because before you didn't have me hey
new girl everybody in this room is about
that superhero life and if you don't
mind my asking where the hell have you
been all this time there are a lot of
other planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
[Music]
I like this one
[Music]
let's go get this son of a [ __ ] for
years I've been treating the Hulk like
he's some kind of disease something to
get rid of but then I start looking at
him as the cure 18 months in a gamble
and I put the brains and the Brawn
together and now they give me best of
both worlds
excuse me miserable yes Julie can we get
photo 100% little person the ones that
bump you mine okay thanks
say green you want to grab one with me
I'm ant-man your Hulk fans wait they
don't know nobody nobody to know you
want you wants to take a picture with
you look he's even saying no he doesn't
I get on the kid on it buddy but you I
don't want a picture with he's gonna
feel happy now you feel bad No gracious
thank you very much Oh God
whoo something died in here
Oh door now you hear about the cable
Cinemax without two weeks ago the sports
row kind of fuzzy oh my god little
rascal honk you know you know my friends
Nico grey hey hey guys long time no see
he is in the pocket feel free to log
into the Wi-Fi no password obviously
Oh clear which way
oh you say something I said I want to
call my eyes out but unfortunately we're
doing it good cuz I already saw the
awfulness will you focus on focus this
pretty place is about to get are gonna
fight real quick buy a bunch of freakin
elves do you know and I saw all these
people who died so this is a little bit
difficult for me okay so once you reach
down deep inside and try and find a
small humanity
this tomato bit give me the thing you
might think I come here you're
embarrassing all right which way you
don't know you used to freaking live
here for 1500 years not forever boy I
think yeah maybe we had that we are so
so ped Tony what's going on tell me you
found that you
you gotta be [ __ ] me
I have eyes on Loki 14th floor I'm not
Loki and I don't want to hurt you I can
do this all day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where did you get this
[Music]
[Music]
you weren't actually born Frank idea of
me was right well imagine your shield
running a quasi mystic intelligence
organization where do you hide it in
plain sight
[Music]
good luck on your mission captain good
luck on your project doctor
you knew here
not exactly
[Music]
we've never seen these two men before no
better time for this - they look for
fishing can you describe me well one of
them had a hippie beard hippie like Bee
Gees of MUNGO JERRY definitely mojo this
is just what I need every available in
the sublevel six weeks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought my dad was tough on me and now
looking back on I just remember the good
stuff
you know he did drop the odd curl yeah
like what no amount of money ever bought
a second of time
smart guy there's best
tell the kids in here yet and there's
nothing I would
[Music]
good to meet you Potts Howard
everything Scooby right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
down to this country
[Music]
you ever met that guy
you read a lot of people so I'm very
familiar weird beard
[Music]
[Music]
I knew right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give me that grab a little
[Music]
what the hell is this Friday what are
they firing at something just entered
the upper atmosphere
[Music]
[Music]
stammers we need an assist here
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Peter Parker hey Peter Parker hi I'm
Peter Parker hey Peter Parker you got
something for me
[Applause]
she's got Hills
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in heaven
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the fight of our lives we are
getting the whole team right oh it's up
regular-sized man hey guys
is that everyone you wanted more
are you crying this is my destiny
Avengers Assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
give me that you have the little one
[Music]
[Music]